the Joe Rogan experience you were one of
the things that you were saying is that
you feel like happiness is something
that you can learn and then you can
teach yourself to be happy even just by
adopting the mindset that you are a
happy person and proclaiming that to
your friends and so you've sort of
developed a social contract I'm a happy
person and though I have to live up to
that yeah that I've got hundreds of
techniques but the models developed that
one oh well there's just a there's
social consistency right humans have a
need to be highly consistent with their
past pronouncements so the way I started
my first tech company was I was in a in
working inside a larger organization and
I told everybody that I was gonna go
start a company it was like I hate this
place and we would do my own thing I'm
gonna be a successful entrepreneur six
months past nine months pass then people
start getting you're still here I
thought you were gonna go start a
company right that was the implication
so we kind of know this right social
contracts are very powerful like if you
want to give up drinking right and
you're not serious about it you'll say
I'm gonna cut back I'm gonna have only
one drink a night I'm gonna only drink
on weekends you tell yourself but if
you're serious you'll announce it on
Facebook you'll tell all your friends
you'll tell your wife you'll say I'm
done drinking I'm throwing everything
out of the house you'll never see me
drink again when you say that you know
you're serious so I think a lot of these
are choices that we make and happiness
is just one of those choices and this is
unpopular to say because there are
people who are actually depressed you
know chemically or what-have-you and
there are people who don't believe that
it's possible because then it creates a
responsibility on them it says oh now if
I'm you're saying if I'm not happy
that's my fault I'm not saying that but
I'm saying that just like Fitness can be
a choice health can be a choice
nutrition can be a choice working hard
and making money can be a choice
happiness is also a choice if you're so
smart how come you aren't happy how can
you haven't figured that out that's my
challenge to all the people who think
they're so smart and so capable if
you're so smart and capable why can't
you change this mmm there are a bunch of
people though that actually take
pleasure and being miserable there's
something about the pursuit of
excellence
and of success that supersedes all other
pursuits that in in their eyes it is it
is that the peak the pinnacle the most
important thing it's not a trade off hmm
I would argue that it now when I say
happy happy is one of those words that
means of zillion different things right
it's like love right what does that mean
cheese yeah I'm gonna find it a little
bit more tightly right so let's go back
to desire right this is old old Buddhist
wisdom I'm not saying anything original
but desire to me is a contract that you
make with yourself to be unhappy until
you get what you want MA and I keep that
in front of mine so when I'm unhappy
about something I look for what is the
underlying desire that I have that's not
being fulfilled it's okay to have
desires you're a biological creature and
you're put on this earth you have to do
something you have to have desires you
have a mission but don't have too many
don't pick them up unconsciously don't
pick them up randomly don't have
thousands of them my coffee is too cold
doesn't taste quite right
I'm not sitting perfectly oh I wish it
would warmer you know my dog
you know pooped in the lawn I didn't
like that whatever it is pick your one
overwhelming desire it's okay to suffer
over that one but on all the others do
you want to let them go so you can be
calm and peaceful and relaxed and then
you'll perform a better job most people
when you're unhappy like a depressed
person it's not that they have very
clear calm mind they're too busy in
their mind the sense of self is too
strong they're sitting indoors all the
time their minds working working working
they're thinking too much well if you
want to be a high-performance athlete
how good of an athlete are you gonna be
if you're always having epileptic
seizures if you're always like twitching
and running around and like jumping and
your your your limbs are flailing out of
control the same way if you want to be
effective in business you need a clear
calm cool collected mind Warren Buffett
plays bridge all day long and goes for
walks in the Sun he doesn't sit around
like constantly loading his brain with
non-stop information and and and getting
worked up about every little thing we
live in an age of infinite leverage what
I mean by that is that your actions can
be multiplied a thousandfold either by
broadcast in a podcast or by investing
capital
having people work for you or by writing
code so because of that the impacts of
good decision-making are much higher
than they used to be because now you can
influence thousands or millions of
people through your decisions or your
code so a clear mind leads to better
judgment leads to better outcome so a
happy calm peaceful person will make
better decisions and have better
outcomes so if you want to operate at
peak performance you have to learn how
to tame your mind just like you have to
learn how to tame your body I love what
you're saying Warren Buffett might not
be the best example because he drinks
like I think six coca-cola's a day and
he eats mostly McDonald's and he's still
alive somehow something shows you that
low stress is more like [ __ ] like how
old is he and he's a fairly old man
Charlie Munger's I think in his 90s
right yeah I made it really far I wonder
what Warren's doing you know I mean just
he's got it no that's bad for him but if
Harold doesn't care he doesn't care I
think he's just a little stress yes
right so he just enjoys that coca-cola
and that's praten maybe there is a
trade-off right maybe him enjoying that
junk food and that Coke just ah that the
pleasing of the mind is maybe better
than him just eating wheatgrass shots
and yeah and because salads and just
being yeah just super a worked up about
everything it's like if you need your
glass of red wine to de-stress and calm
down that's probably better than you
flying off the rails right right and I
think that that's applicable not just in
business but in probably any pursuit and
I like what you're saying about allow
that one thing to be your obsession but
everything else just you know learn how
to learn how to let things go pick your
battles and we like to think that we
like to view the world as linear which
is I'm gonna put in eight hours of work
I'm gonna get back eight hours of output
right doesn't work that way a guy
running the corner grocery store is
working just as hard or harder than you
and me how much output is he getting
what you do who you do with how you do
it way more important than how hard you
work right now it puts our nonlinear
based on the quality of the work that
you put in the right way that work is
like a lion you don't you and I are not
like cows
not meant to graze all day right we're
meant to hunt like lions we're closer to
carnivores in our omnivorous development
than we are to herbivores
we can't tell vegans that yeah sorry
look I wish all that stuff worked I
don't want to eat meat this future
generation will look back at us as worse
than slavers you know because the
Holocaust were committing with the
animals but they'll have artificial
meats that taste in our healthier is
better than the real thing
so allegedly allegedly but so ISM as a
modern knowledge worker athlete as an
intellectual athlete you want to
function like an athlete which means you
train hard then you sprint then you rest
then you reassessed you get your
feedback loop then you train some more
then you sprint again then you rest
then you reassess this idea that you're
gonna have linear output just by
cranking every day at the same amount of
time sitting that's that's machines you
know machines should be working 9:00 to
5:00 humans are not meant work 9:00 are
not meant to work 9:00 to 5:00 no I
agree wholeheartedly but it's it did for
people that are working for someone
there's not really that option so that's
unfortunately the the rub right that is
kind of where my tweet storm starts
which is first of all the first thing if
you're gonna make money is that you're
not gonna get rich renting at your time
even lawyers and doctors were charging
three four five hundred dollars an hour
they're not getting rich because their
lifestyle slowly ramping up along with
their income and they're not saving
enough they just don't have that ability
retire so the first thing you have to do
is you have to own a piece of a business
you need to have equity either as an
owner and investor shareholder or a
brand that you're building that accrues
to you to gain your financial freedom
[Applause]